Today Spain has -as I said- 1 complex resolution or elections are repeated
with the risk that the political balances will end up being as fragile
as those of today or agree with 1 party that maintains the October 1 machinery
and that has notd or will not unilateralism as a legitimate resource to
assert the interests of the Catalan people.
Neither of the 2 major Spanish parties has enough strength to prevail over the
other Neither of them has 1 alliance that provides them with 1 solid and coherent
majority in Cara in a position to agree And they are not yet in a position to
agree between them or elections or pact with us or 1/3 option that is not unprecedented
in Spanish politics that some deputies of the
progressive bloc leave their votes.
for the investiture of the right-wing candidate.